is there a way to break up with someone
that a new tackle isn't your new audio
book is there a proper way to break up
with people because it seems like it's a
no-win situation it's really tough
because if you text someone a breakup
which happens all day every day
girls are so incensed like this [ __ ]
guy texted me right but I'm like hey I
wish there was something less than text
I didn't want to do that yeah cuz you
still get a reaction who wants to sit
there and have the horrible face to face
because I text a girl once and she goes
you text it to breakup
yeah what do you say hi kid so what do
you say I mean cuz it always does come
off kind of lame like what do you well I
have only gotten ghosts so I when grows
break up with me I mean ghosted meaning
it used to be called me old days fizzled
out right they go you're still seeing
Sara go we kind of fizzled out here's
one fizzles out I heard she's [ __ ]
another guy I'm breaking up with her now
alright because she's screwing another
guy actively so nowadays with other
technologies like if I ago I texted and
the girl goes he doesn't even call me
Brian not even a man right and then you
call them they go you didn't do it in
person right called me and then you do
in person I go
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] broke up with me
you're like there's no wind there's no
situation where they go you know what he
was great about it we had a really clean
break because even if you do it in
person are you saying even if you do it
in person you're saying to put you you
know what I had to go get dressed up and
go leave my hat and you should have just
called me they told me they just hate
that it's a breakup so every any
scenario is bad and in person I've done
it and it's the same if I ever girls
dumping me and I've done this I go oles
me me and talk to me like shoo stuck you
owe me that as a girls always tell me
you owe me that David this all sounds
like a tremendous hassle when you
describe it I would think at this point
you're just kidding is texting that you
say it's the coward's way out but yet
maybe you're right maybe that's what and
what are you right what do you write to
somebody that someone's 50 saying they
text about it
it's bright yeah I mean you're like
weird then I don't know what I write
usually emojis will tell the story have
you figured out how to write alone 9
emojis together what a mode you'd have
to go to it
expert and I figured out